animation disparu en ville ils sont
d'autant plus visibles et leur dénuement
poignant combien de sans abri dorment
temps ce moment dans les rues de fort de
france 2 sont ceux dont la ville
peut-être plus et pour leur venir en
aide les bénévoles du loft challenge ont
activé leurs réseaux
ils viennent désormais chaque dimanche
distribués de quoi tenir quelques jours
aujourd'hui à bas l arrivée avec la
salade et des accents et on a légumes
alors d'achille et banham jeunes highco
rouge et viennent de pau on essaie de
toujours avoir un panier est équilibré
pour qu'ils aient quelque chose de
consistant pour les joueurs de lier des
amis et puis on essaie d'avoir des
choses qui puisse le rappeler la période
dans laquelle on est donc en janvier ont
fait la galère les très bons en février
et en mars
on a fait deux acren ont fait les
chocolats c'est surtout cette fois ci
pour certains sont des habitués de ce
rendez vous
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de gens qui font des mini
combo j'ai beaucoup donné pour ne pas
beaucoup de russes tous sont
agréablement surpris de ne pas avoir été
oublié un dimanche de pâques
aujourd'hui ça c'est bien sûr vie des
paiements tine des jus d'orange ça va
c'est bien bah oui elle est belle et
puis la gastronomie c'est quoi comme on
dit ça le triton la semelle et et non
sur les quais lochard à chahbounia sinon
moi je me tape les mango qui sont à la
ville les fruits qui sont dans les
arabes les mango moi je pense plus à
ceux qui sont chez eux
bon courage c'est le troisième dimanches
d'affilée que la distribution se fait à
fort de france
à chaque fois de nouveaux volontaires
viennent appuyer le dispositif fait
c'est le coeur en fête c'est le fait de
donner tout simplement j'ai trouvé le
geste le geste beau surtout en cette
période ils sont seuls n'y a pas de ya
pas vraiment de deux passants pour
demander pourra les aider
voilà donc on les abandonne pas chaque
semaine les demandeurs semble se faire
plus nombreux ils ont dormi dans
l'entrée d'un commerce ou en bord de mer
aujourd'hui plus que jamais le nombre de
sans abri show prend les bénévoles ne
sait jamais
je vais beaucoup depuis le confinement
nous avons beaucoup de sans abri qui
courent après bravo - paquet c'est pas
facile on se retrouve à 70,6 je me
demande si on aura assez même si la
suisse prend en charge de nombreuses
personnes plus nombreux encore sont
celles qui échappent tête tout
dispositif et le love challenge
multiplient les appels aux dons
c'est peut-être plus difficile puisque
d'habiter des gens là ils vont vers les
petits commerçants locaux les petites
boutiques de de pauw tapoter pong c'est
de gagner un petit peu d'argent aussi
puisqu'il est un petit peu les
commerçants ou bien des petits plus
pouvoir se nourrir mais pratiquement
tout est fait au mieux donc ils ont un
seul coup c'est devenu v on nous dit
maintenant on va te donner un tir de dix
minutes
notre jeunesse est devenue contiennent
et leurs partenaires
on essaie de de se frapper à toutes les
portes
il voit aussi ils peuvent nous aider
parce qu'on en a besoin c'est pas pour
moi
si pour les sans abri super boulot peut
pas ça fait plaisir qu'on ne lâche pas
on me fait plaisir
vous êtes en est une où voici beaucoup
volontaires donateurs personnes privées
ou entreprises sont plus que jamais
sollicitée pour que l'oph challenge soit
encore en action dimanche prochain et
jusqu'à la fin du confinement